You should give up and call the nurse.
You won't make it beyond this point.
Hmm? Oh, yeah, the broom!
I don't mind some scratches! One or two
or three or four or five or six!
I'm going to get on that broom
no matter what!
You can't shake me off!
I'm going to hang on
until the end of the world!
Currently in first place is
the reliable cool beauty Diana!
Can she manage to hold on?
I'm worried about Akko.
Maybe she gave up and retired somewhere.
Someone else is gaining on her... Akko!
-Akko is flying on a broom!
-You're kidding.
Akko?
In third place is the dark horse,
the rebellious Amanda!
It's my broom. Give it back to me!
Hey, Akko!
Amanda is disqualified.
She failed to grab the baton!
It's not a baton, but a doughnut!
What a development!
It's now a race between Diana and Akko!
Amazing! Akko is flying on a broom!
She's just hanging on to it.
It's still amazing! Go, Akko!
They are neck and neck!
They are now in the homestretch!
Who's going to win?